hello everyone today we'll go over the
step-by-step instructions to add an
additional key using this Pro key box
kit we will be demonstrating how to
program the key fob and it is the same
procedures if you just programming
transponder key to begin you must have
one working key to add additional key
this kit is compatible with 2011 to 2017
Honda Odyssey I will list compatibility
guide at the end of this video this kit
comes with the aftermarket key the
programmer tool and the instruction
manual if you have your own unprogrammed
key you can also purchase the programmer
tool separately this tool will work on
any aftermarket or original key today
we'll program the aftermarket key with
the kit once you use this programmer
tool it will lock to your Carin this
means you can reuse in your vehicle but
not in other vehicle make sure to cut
the keyblade first before you begin
programming so to begin the process
insert your working key into the
ignition and start the
car then you need to connect the tool to
the OBD port
then press enter to continue the
programmer will communicate to your
vehicle when you hear the beeping tone
turn the ignition off and remove the key
now insert the new key into the ignition
and turn it to
onpos do not start the
engine turn the key to off
[Music]
position turn it back to on
position the programmer will communicate
to your vehicle
turn the key to off
position turn it back to on
position once here the beeping sound
indicating programming is
successful this means it is all
done so next unplug the tool and let's
test the key fob
here we can see it's working and it's
all good to go repeat the steps if you
have more keys to program hope you
enjoyed the video thank you for watching